welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney  eric palacios and today we're going to  tell you three things you should do if  you're involved in a car accident number  one call the police this way you can  establish who's at fault and have a  police report done so you can open a  claim with the insurance company later  number two if it's safe to do so take  pictures or videos of the cars before  you move them this way you can show the  police later how the accident took place  number three obtain the other drivers  information this includes taking a photo  of their driver's license insurance card  and registration if you do these three  things you will be protected this has  been your legal minute remember to  download my app eric palacio's legal app